I'd encourage you to get the notebook as
I usually do it my talks there will be
things in the notebook that I don't
cover here they'll be labeled in that
notebook as bonus sections I will not
open the bonus sections during this talk
the bonus sections are for you when you
get the notebook back into the quiet of
your own workspace and to see some
additional information hopefully useful
sometimes humorous and I'm going to be
talking about principles of dynamic
interfaces this is not a talk I've given
in the past although it covers some of
the same information dynamic hasn't
changed a whole lot but I think we've
learned a lot about how to use it so
people in the back row tell me when to
stop up magnifying here is that enough
that's okay okay so I'm going to be
talking a little bit about so so so the
talk is going to be highlighting a few
sort of high-level principles of how to
handle approaching interface programming
in Mathematica how to approach handling
dynamics and sprinkled throughout i'll
be offering some essential concepts and
some key techniques for for using
dynamics okay so start off in a
high-level principles these actually
were were uncovered by mr. John foltz a
few years back and try as I might I
couldn't improve on them for this year
so these are the same principles that
John Illustrated some years back
principle of programmatic generation
principle of minimal dynamics principle
of maximum capsulation principle of
evaluation blocking if you see anybody
taking pictures of the screen please let
them know that the notebook is going to
be on passable is unpassable hit them
with your elbow or whatever you need to
do to get them to stop to stop taking
pictures so programmatic generation this
shouldn't come as a surprise to anybody
you're a you're at a Wolfram language
conference and best way to generate
interfaces and Wolfram language is to
use the Wolfram language not to sort of
edit the interface files directly but to
struct a program that generates the
interface so what does that mean what
kinds of what kinds of features do we
have for generating interfaces for
putting these things together well there
are a set of dynamic primitives these
are the things that underlie the
controls themselves the the dynamic and
dynamic module allow you to have this
nice bi-directional communication
between your controls and expressions or
between expressions and other
expressions we have a rich control
language including button checkbox radio
button I didn't list them all here we
have we have nice locator pain which is
our sort of you know multi thumb direct
direct access controls we also have a
low level event or event handling system
and all of these are listed on these on
these help pages in addition to the
controls and dynamics we have you know a
rich styling language rich layout
language panel grid styling Jason showed
some styling and I'm not going to be
talking much about the styling this talk
is mostly about the dynamic stuff but I
wanted to make sure to give at least a
nod of the cap to these guys and for
wrapping up the interfaces of course you
have deployed create palette create
dialogue these kinds of things and in
provided with Mathematica we take two
different approaches to giving you
interfaces there are interfaces built in
the Wolfram language that are built once
and then burned into the product that we
ship you so the about box is a notebook
that we've that someone has you know
written some code to generate that about
that notebook is saved pushed into the
layout shipped off to you preferences
dialog is a notebook the help you were
toolbar is a cell resource all the
things in this list and more are
resources that are sort of built once
and then deployed as as finalized things
and then there's the set of interfaces
that you know they're not generated
beforehand that they're generated at the
instant that you press shift enter so if
you have a manipulate expression that
manipulate didn't exist before you
evaluate it
there's a body of code that ships with
Mathematica that gets run when you
request a manipulate likewise for
Wolfram Alpha output in Mathematica
system information and several other
things are all code based okay so I'm
going to cover a little bit about what
the dynamic primitives are and the
majority of this talk is going to be
about certain features of the dynamic
primitives but I wanted to give sort of
a baseline understanding of what these
guys are so dynamic is is a is a rapper
that you can you know put around around
an expression and the output of that the
typeset output of that should look like
the value of that expression right now
so dynamic of X the output of that
should look like the value of x right
now if X were to change because of some
other evaluation the output should also
update to what X looks like right now if
you had exchanging more quickly that
dynamic should always be what the value
of x is right now right so so these are
display dynamics when when a display
dynamic is handled the how does how does
Mathematica know that when X changes it
needs to change that rectangle on the
screen well when it's first evaluated
the evaluation goes through the colonel
in such a way that the colonel tracks
all the symbols on which that rectangle
depends this case it's very simple it
only depends on one symbol so the
dependency graph is built the simple
graph and we see just a simple symbol in
it but you could have more complicated
dependency graphs so for instance here
is a rather unimaginative stack of
functions f depends on G and a G depends
on h & B H depends on nothing and we
have dynamic of f of 3 so this has you
know this output depends on F depends on
G depends on a if you change the value
of a
the output changes if you change the
definition of G the output changes so
any piece of the dependency graph is
going to trigger updates to this piece
of dynamic output and it's not going to
trigger updates to other dynamic outputs
that don't depend on those symbols right
so each dynamic output is is is handled
separately again the bonus sections I'm
not going to be opening at this talk
please get the notebook open them
yourselves enjoy okay so so dynamic
wants to be wants to show you what the
value would be right now of course right
now really means it might be okay for an
expression that only updates once twice
three times here we have an example of
an expression that's updating as fast as
it can in fact it's the dynamic that's
pushing the updates so dynamic of
pre-increment of see you know evaluates
pre-increment to see what does that
depend on well it depends on the value
of C so the value of C changes during
the evaluation pre-increment of C so
there must be another dynamic update
during that next dynamic update the
value of C changes again and so we have
a dynamic that that runs on here
sometimes this is what you want
sometimes you self running dynamics or a
very useful way to drive animations to
run models but not sometimes it's not
and there are primitives that one can
use to restrict the scope of the
dependency graph so track symbols is an
option that lets you say I don't care
about this symbol don't let changes to
this symbol trigger dynamic updates for
this dynamic update interval is another
option that says if there hasn't been a
dynamic update in this number of seconds
trigger one so here we've now throttled
back this pre-increment of c loop so
that it doesn't update by virtue of C
changing it updates by virtue of time
passing right okay
if I did not if I had not set an update
interval it would update once and then
be done yes which also sometimes is
useful Thank You time so on the flip
side of that sometimes updates are too
frequent but sometimes they're too rare
and you can use the same kinds of
handles for forgetting track of those
one thing I'll point out is track
symbols is not an additive option track
symbols does not let you declare a
dependence that wasn't there to begin
with so if you had if so here we have
dynamic of date string date string
doesn't depend on the value of C I'm
trying to say well I wanted to depend on
see that's not how track symbols works
if we change the value of C this dynamic
is not going to update that's not track
symbols is not additive it doesn't say
you know update based on values based on
updates to this symbol no matter what
it's this symbol if it's in the
dependency tree and you can you can
force it to be in the dependency tree if
you've really wanted to I suppose that's
occasionally useful and now we see
updates to the date but just just to
sort of set clear what what track
symbols is it's it's subtractive not at
addition yeah because that's that's the
useful thing I mean why would you want a
dynamic to depend on some spooky action
at a distance symbol yeah well and you
can do that with with this technique yes
right so you want you want yes you want
a feature we don't have then that's
correct right and we've already talked
about update interval okay so in
addition to wanting to be current
dynamic wants to be seen nothing is
guaranteed to happen when dynamics are
off-screen when dynamics are hidden in
some way if they're not shown and a
piece of typeset output nothing is going
to happen if we evaluate dynamic of
setting some variable did that variable
get a value well not yet so here we have
a somewhat more interesting example we
have a notebook that has a dynamic and a
closed section so we have an expression
cell and a closed section has has very
gotten a dynamic has has it gotten a
value yet know when we open this cell
when we open the cell group now the
expression goes through now it becomes
visible on screen and the dynamic
updates so dynamic really wants to be
seen but it doesn't want to be seen by
you it updates when it needs to be seen
by the front end and the reason that
that distinction is interesting is
because sometimes the front end needs to
render these expressions before you see
them or even if you never see them a
good example of that are a collection of
objects that basically their purpose is
to show a set of exempt a set of
expressions but only one at a time we
have tab view pane selector these kinds
of things shows one expression at a time
but with the default styling for tab
view the front end wants to know the
size of all of the tab pains in order to
size the overall tab view right so it
needs to actually render every one of
the tabs that's why this tab view is so
big because the default image size for
tab view is all so it looked through
here and found the widest pain and the
tallest pain and sized accordingly this
is fine and it's useful but
it's occasionally quite thorny and let
me get the messages window up here I
want to show you something okay so why
is this thorny why am I even mentioning
this and talk about dynamic well so here
we have a tab view each tab has a
dynamic around its contents you know
this is very common sort of idiom for
building interfaces you have one tab
does one set of things and it needs a
dynamic display another tab has another
thing but you want those dynamics to
sort of wait until you switch to that
tab to update by default it doesn't wait
the front-end won't wait it will the
messages window is showing you that both
of these tabs were formatted the very
first go right I haven't yet visited the
first tab but both the first and second
had been formatted and now they don't
need to be formatted again how do you
avoid this issue well if the front-end
didn't need to size the tab view as the
largest thing it wouldn't have to scan
through all the tabs and so the way to
avoid it is to set image size to
automatic now we see when you're viewing
the first pain the first dynamic fires
and only when we switch to the second
pain does the second dynamic fire yeah
so I think this is very useful
um yes any as long as all is neither the
width nor the height of the tab view
this will this will be fine so automatic
or a fixed or a fixed number four with
their height yes okay so that's that's a
programmatic evaluation and a little bit
of discussion about the dynamic
primitives we have the next principle
principle of minimal dynamics is an
attempt to express that you know
dynamics should never try to do more
than it needs to there might be certain
bits of your evaluation that don't need
to be run dynamically they can just be
run once upfront and you know this this
will change for all of for each of your
applications but i think the principle
is is rather accessible to everyone so
in the simplest form here i just have
you know a check box i have dynamic
wrapped around a big block of code that
i copied out of the help viewer I think
it's math or something so so we have a
check box that when pressed changes the
value of this simple this expression
depends on this symbol so whenever the
value of that symbol changes this whole
expression will get rerun the ND solve
gets rerun the density plot gets rerun
and so it takes a healthy second every
time i press this check box for this for
this to update well you know where this
is going the ND solve certainly doesn't
need to be rerun every time I change
this check box so as a first
approximation of getting this faster why
not just wrap the dynamic around the
density plot the solution to the
differential equation can just happen
once and that gives us a benefit it's
still not fast but it's faster and for
visualization functions we have an
additional level we can push the dynamic
all the way down around the option
setting so that the only thing changing
is the value of this option in the front
end the solution isn't change the the
density plot doesn't need to be rerun
and we evaluate this and we have now a
check box that is working as fast as it
can
that's correct that's correct there are
there are this this works for options
which are resolved by the front end yes
so there are there are places there are
I guess the point of this slide is is
pushing the dynamic down as far as you
can but no further yeah in addition to
just have single dynamics at the correct
level you can have multiple dynamics
nested together and here i have an
academic example that attempts to show
this when you do this nesting you know
when you update a dynamic that entire
dynamic content gets replaced which you
haven't if you have an outer dynamic and
an inner dynamic you update the outer
dynamic both dynamics get replaced you
update the inner dynamic that can update
separately all by itself without
updating the outer one so here we're
also going to use this messages window
to take a look at what's happening so we
have you know X is in the outer X is is
you know in the outside and why is is
somewhere inside this frame we change
the value of x and we see x and y
changing right we see inner and outer
echoes being produced whereas if we
change just the variable that drives the
inner dynamic x need not change this is
just driving changes to why there's only
inner updates happening here yeah so
nesting dynamics again a very very
useful idiom
okay and sometimes the answer to minimal
dynamics is well can you have zero and
there are some unique features in the
desktop front-end that lets you get by
with not having dynamics and still
building interfaces that look like maybe
you did use dynamic these are bonus
sections so I can't open them but I'd
encourage you to take a look okay so
that's minimum dynamics then I'm going
to talk a little bit about encapsulation
and the principle of maximum capsulation
states that you should have when you
deliver your interface to someone should
have everything that it needs and
nothing extra shouldn't infect the user
system with stuff that it doesn't need
we've already talked about two different
ways that you might do this you might
deliver finished notebooks the way that
the mathematical layout does you might
supply code that creates interfaces on
the fly the way that manipulate and
friends do common to both these
approaches is use of a construct dynamic
module this is a very useful construct
that we developed when first building
manipulate some years back and it's
useful for the following reasons why
would you want to use a custom scoping
construct in the front end rather than
just using block or module well block is
fine but it doesn't really isolate
things fully you know it still is
changing global state module module
scopes things during the colonel
evaluation by virtue of these temporary
variables yeah based on dollar module
number which is fine but interfaces
don't exist in the kernels of evaluation
q they exist sort of on your you know
they exist in your notebooks you make a
copy of an interface make a copy of an
interface well I'll use my first example
here so you make a copy of an interface
should these two have the same X all
right i mean this is this is a
fundamental question if we have them if
we have manipulative x this uses dynamic
module to do it scoping you know this is
not the globe
x the global x is not changing when I
want to interact with this manipulate
but what if I were to make a copy of the
output well if this were just some
output generated from some kernel
evaluation of module so it have the same
temporary variables it would be the same
X that's not good enough for manipulate
if you make a copy of this you don't
want outputs to sort of be dependent on
other outputs so we have we have dynamic
module being able to scope things in a
region on the screen rather than in a
region of colonel evaluation one way
this is sometimes described is module
scopes in time colonel valuation time
and dynamic module scopes in space and
these rectangles on the screen yeah so
scoping is a very useful way to reason
to use dynamic module another is that it
automatically saves State for you and if
you've used manipulate you know this I'm
not going to show an example you have a
manipulate you slide the sliders around
save the notebook close down go to sleep
travel to urbana open up your notebook
all the sliders have the same state
where you left them this is not
something that manipulate built this was
built as part of dynamic module so it
gives you it gives you this for free
just by using dynamic module dynamic
module also gives you a place to store
initialization code so in a pre dynamic
world we had initialization cells you
open up a notebook you try to evaluate
something you get this blob that says I
think there's some initialization here
do you want me to run it for you and we
still support that model but in the
modern world from dynamic interfaces
that didn't really work for us because
we wanted the ability to open up a
notebook and have dynamics automatically
start moving around so we have dynamic
module as a construct that when it is
first displayed every time an instance
of this dynamic module is first
displayed its initialization option is
run and this is useful I mean you can
imagine how this is useful for
deployment you put your your utility
symbols
definitions in the initialization and
there you go can be somewhat awkward to
populate this manually although
sometimes it's useful other times it's
useful to populate it automatically so
save definitions used to be just an
option to manipulate now it's also an
option to dynamic module if you set save
definitions true for a dynamic module it
will automatically slurp in the full
definition of every symbol that appears
in the manipulate so among other things
it will get the kernel notion of full
definition of the function that we're
that is referred to and this dynamic
module and it will embed that in the
initialization option of the generated
dynamic module so if we were to look at
the input form of this we would see it's
a dynamic module and this dynamic module
doesn't have saved definitions anymore
it has a literal initialization which
was created as a side effect of save
definitions true yes
yes the question is the question is if
you had if you use both save definitions
true and a literal initialization do
they play well together and the answer
is yes I forget which one goes first and
which one go second but but yes they're
there they're thrown in together yes I'm
sorry the X ah yes Marcus is pointing
out that that save definitions is often
not what you want because not only did
it slurp in the value of my funk it's
lurked in a global value from X because
well you know what look there's an X
there and that's because well every
symbol in the dynamic module is affected
by save definitions and if we look at
the full definition of X sure enough it
has a value so this is something you
should be aware of when using save
definitions it is not it is not for
everyone and if you have global state
that you're worried about getting saved
you may want to use literal
initialization settings rather than save
definitions right
ok I think we're right on time so what
are some other useful techniques when
dealing with dynamic module well just
like when dealing with module you want
to be careful about how you pass local
variables to other utilities so I'm
going to show sort of a common
misapplication of dynamic module and how
to fix it so clearly we want some way to
break up you know a code base so that
you don't have an entire interface
designed and deployed inside or written
in Wolfram language code in a single
dynamic module manipulate was not
written as a single dynamic module in
some in some Wolfram language code file
that was millions of lines long it's
modular and likewise if you wanted to
modularize this interface how might you
do it well we have control block we have
a display block maybe we can maybe we
can separate those out we say okay I
want the controls to be this the display
to be this and then we're going to
assemble those things into a column of
controls and display looks great right
but it's not going to work and it's not
going to work because of the details of
how these variables were passed through
to utilities it's a good architecture I
encourage you to use modular
implementations but you need to be
careful about how you pass things around
so what happened here was well dynamic
module initialized a to the value 1 and
then controls of a well that's controls
of one so we get controls of one that's
slider of dynamic of one well that's not
going to work we want slider of dynamic
of a how do you handle this well in the
old world you use use holding attributes
on your functions use hold first hold
all something I think in well so this is
so you're only getting the passing the
value of the symbol not the symbol
itself not not not the symbol by
reference and and yes you can you can
add holding attributes
the way that I prefer to do it is to use
the same model used by our control
language bypassing dynamic a variable
through as the argument to your
utilities so here I have controls of
dynamic of variable dynamic is a hold
first construct in the kernel right it's
not going to evaluate its its its
expression its argument so controls of
dynamic of a is not going to pass the
value of a it's going to pass a by
reference and so this is a this is a
refactoring that that will work we have
controls of dynamic of a display of
dynamic of a and now the utilities get
the appropriate local variable from the
dynamic module and all good and if you
really like using whole first and hold
all you can use those but I prefer this
this model okay so first half of my talk
was the first three principles second
half is I'm hoping going to be filled
with the last principle the principle of
evaluation blocking this is the idea
that there are two kinds of dynamic
updates there are updates that happen
quickly there are updates that happen
slowly and knowing when to use each can
often be the difference between writing
an application that's responsive and
usable and irie an application that
shows you dollar aborted and spending
beach balls and all kinds of other nasty
stuff and rather than digging straight
into the terminology of of how we
express these notions and dynamic going
to talk to you about grocery stores so
so say you have a grocery store that has
to checkout lanes you know there's an
express lane for the people that have
six items or less and then there's the
guys who have their full carts and they
can go through some you know some main
checkout Lane further suppose that there
is a single clerk working at this store
and that single clerk is staffing both
of these
Lane's right and whenever somebody gets
into the express lane the clerk goes
over and takes care of them right away
and then gets back to whatever they were
doing in the main lane somebody takes
too long the express lane they get
kicked out right so this is essentially
this is essentially what's happening
with our dynamic system we have a single
kernel a single you know computational
engine I'm going to shrink this just for
a second and it's servicing two
different kinds of evaluations it's
servicing main loop evaluations that can
take as long as you want you know these
are the evaluations that have been
around since the beginning you start
something on a Monday it finishes a week
from Thursday it can run and run and run
these are some of the terms that I might
use to refer to them cute evaluations
there asynchronous in our dynamic
nomenclature and some controls are
called method queued and others they're
called synchronous updating false
synchronous initialization false and
there are some other ways to access main
loop cute evaluations in the express
lane the fast stuff you'll hear me talk
about pre-emptive evaluations on the
pre-emptive link you'll hear me talk
about synchronous updating true or
synchronous controls and so on so we
have we have very much this situation in
in our system and stay out of the
express lane if you're going slow and
I'll come back to that let me go back up
for Jason okay so letting slow things be
slow there's there's no there's no shame
in a computation taking more than a few
seconds but you do need to accommodate
it in your interfaces any interface that
asks the user for something in a
blocking way so if you use system
dialogue input and try to call that from
a button this first input is going to
fail because users you know some users
are going to interact quickly with this
interface and they'll get in under the
what is it six second deadline for
pre-emptive evaluations preemptive value
it's not just that they should be fast
it's
force that they are fast and if they
take longer than a few seconds the front
end will actively kill them so if you
expect your users to be that fast in a
dialogue you're you're in for a world of
hurt this is the right way to do that
for buttons you say you tell the button
you know what this might take a while so
use the queued link you use use a cute
evaluation here when interacting with
the network I'm not going to bother
evaluating this because I understand
that the network is rather flaky here in
this room whenever interacting with any
network known or unknown it might take
longer than you think there might be
some network hiccups there might be
something going on with some dns server
somewhere use synchronous updating
asynchronous updating use queued
evaluation in this case so here we have
a call to the passable API maybe I'll
try evaluating this so this is going to
go off and well that wasn't so bad so it
was like gray rectangle that was the
front end saying I i have stuff that's
coming back for this you know hold a
place for me so use use synchronous
updating false whenever you have network
transactions whenever you have a
complicated graphic or an extensive
report that might take more than a few
seconds use the slow lane anything that
might take more than a couple seconds
use the slow lane otherwise i'll try
evaluate oh I even made those unev al
you a table put my clever so so
synchron's in dining in the dynamic
dynamic module world that's synchronous
updating false for dynamic and for a
long-running dynamic module
initialization its synchronous
initialization false right
okay so building on that we have these
two lanes we have evaluations happening
on both of them are there interesting
things that can be done by employing
both links simultaneously well since I'm
up here in front of you and I asked the
question the answer is probably yes so
one nice way that we've built on top of
having these two links is being able to
show you what's going on with an
evaluation while it's happening you know
the colonel has always had this notion
of dialogues or sub sessions and the
pre-emptive evaluation sort of formalize
that and here we have you know a stack
of technology that while it's running so
there's I've you shift enter to kick
this off it's a cute evaluation a
long-running do loop in the first
argument to this monitor oops I'm going
to re-evaluate the first one so that
cute evaluation is happening during that
cute evaluation there are dynamic
updates happening synchronously so the
first thing this does this monitor does
is it prints out dynamic of I and then
that synchronous dynamic can update
during this cute evaluation so so we
have a long-running evaluation
triggering updates and shorter running
evaluations and the monitor that gets
printed can have any form I mean this is
Mathematica you could be arbitrarily
clever here we have dedicated progress
indication kinds of things but you can
build your own you can you can do all
kinds of stuff right and there are a
couple of other primitives that I've
listed here that you might be interested
in if you're interested in this kind of
stuff and as I said what's really
happening here is you have a cute
evaluation that happens to be setting a
variable and that changes to that
variable are triggering these other
dynamics to update and here I've kind of
teased that a part of it I have a cute
evaluation this time being started by a
button not by shift return and I have a
synchronous dynamic that's watching the
value of this particular variable and by
clicking this button
you know during the evaluation of that
button function I should I guess I
should maybe highlight what that button
function is during the evaluation of
this do loop you know the value the
global value of C is changing and this
other dynamic is watching the global
value of C and every time it changes it
kind of pics a new value it's not
showing all of them notice it's showing
them at about 20 a second or so but so
this is this is the kind of approach
this is a very useful approach when you
want to provide some sort of feedback in
your interfaces for long-running
evaluations I think I remember hearing
not long after I started working at
Wolfram that Apple tweaked the speed of
the spinning beachball because even
though the computer was stuck not doing
anything the speed at which the beach
ball spun gave users more of a good
feeling if the beach while expending
faster that meant up there everything's
okay so as interface programmer's I'd
encourage you all to make sure that your
users know what's going on in your
interfaces and I'm not going to run the
second example because it doesn't work
it's there as an example of what not to
do um and these are built out a little
bit more you can look at these at your
leisure it's the same kind of thing a
cube button driving a long-running
evaluation and a synchronous dynamic
showing progress in this case it shows
both progress and what happens when the
evaluation completes so we have you know
a spinner and then it's replaced by the
result of the evaluation I'm going to
come back to this example and a little
bit and tell you why it's why it's not
quite good enough for production code
it's pretty good but it's not quite good
enough in the wild another thing I'll
mention as long as we're talking about
method options is I don't know if we
made a big to-do about this but we did
add method support to event handler in
version 10 too so
so I think method would method cute and
method pre-emptive were only supported
by button and action menu per hour prior
to that and now we have support for that
an event handler which can be very
useful here's an example so button in
graphics uses event handler so cute
buttons in graphics you know wrap
directly around graphics primitives used
to not used to not work but now does
because we have we have button based on
event handler now supports method cube
so here we have you know a graphic that
when you click it goes off and does
nothing for a second and then changes
the color of the disk yeah it's kind of
fun actually okay so what else is there
say well there are some other
interesting uses of having these two
lengths one you may have noticed all on
your own so if you had a complicated
visualization function plot 3ds
parametric plot 3d something like this
you start dragging around controls you
notice the mesh lines go away and you
get this sort of jagged display it's
fast but it doesn't really look all that
great and then when you release the
mouse things snap back into focus the
mesh lines come back you get this
beautiful rendering how does this work
how can I use this in my own interfaces
well there's two pieces to this there's
a new rapper called control active and
there's a setting for synchronous
updating that I haven't talked about yet
so control active takes two arguments
takes an argument it takes basically a
fast rendering and a beautiful rendering
the assumption that the fast rendering
is going to evaluate quickly the
beautiful rendering might take a little
bit longer but it's just a wrapper that
that contains sort of two things and
automatically switches to the fast
rendering while you're interacting with
controls and to the slow rendering when
you let them go synchronous updating
automatic is the front ends way of
saying I know better than you do when it
comes to deciding which links to use and
when the front end decides which links
to use it can switch back and forth
between them for the same
dynamic so we can say for some updates
i'm going to use the pre-emptive fast
lane and for others i'm going to use the
cued slow lane put that together with
control active you have a fast preview
that gets through on the preemptive link
notice among other things that the cell
bracket is not highlighting here all of
these all of these evaluations are
pre-emptive and as soon as I release
this cell bracket highlights control
active switches to the other state and
that beautiful rendering now goes to the
queued link and can take as long as it
wants to come back of course this is
exactly what you want for responsive
interfaces you don't want every drag of
this slider to have to take five seconds
to produce a new beautiful graphic you
could certainly produce a better fast
rendering by you direct use of control
active and here I have sort of an
example of direct use of control active
again it's a dry academic example but
hopefully it gives you a flavor for
what's happening we have a slider and we
have a control active in a dynamic the
fast rendering is just the value of the
variable the slow rendering the
artificially slow rendering is the value
of the variable and a panel with
synchronous updating automatic the magic
happens so we drag the slider we see
just the value we let go the slider
takes a second come back with the
beautiful rendering anything at all can
go in the first or second arguments to
control active so here's an example of a
solution to a stack overflow question
from a couple years ago I think we're
control active it's fast rendering is
sort of a simple graphic it's richer
it's richer expression is not just
another graphic it's a dynamic module
construct with an asynchronous
initialization so this graph this this
control active payload fills in a little
at a time so we drag this around faster
rendering is just a purple circle slow
rendering goes off and runs some
iterative thing where the graph
is being updated over time and now we're
done okay so some of you may have found
the option that controls how fast what
the throttle is that the front end uses
for pre-emptive evaluations what the
timeout setting is encourage you not to
change that value and instead as you as
interface programmer's you know design
for things that are slow to use the
queued evaluation modes and things
they're fast only to use the pre-emptive
modes yeah ok so we've seen how cute
evaluations can affect synchronous
updates or can trigger sickness updates
I'd like to show you sort of the
opposite so we have button event handler
Action menu are controls that can
directly kick off cute evaluations what
if I want a cute evaluation kicked off
by a checkbox or a radio button how do I
do that well turns out it's not that
hard and here's one example of how you
might choose to do that using a
constructor it's basically it's a lot
like dynamic except it lets you say what
you want to display and separately say
what you want to track dynamically it
doesn't display the thing you're
tracking dynamically so it's going to
display as a check box attached to a
dynamic variable and its payload the
thing that it's going to update is well
if this variable is in the true state
then it's going to to run some some
other code it's going to do that
asynchronously so this checkbox a
synchronous control is going to kick off
an asynchronous computation and the net
effect of that is you know we have a
checkbox note the cell bracket lit up
and this goes off and works for a while
and comes back so we have a switching to
the false stating happens switching to
the true state goes off and and
percolates for a while and then comes
back so there's a lot of flexibility
with with having these evaluations
happening on one
triggering evaluations on other links
but it really does require that you put
a little bit of thought into how these
things are architected people who are
seriously interested in these kinds of
things I would encourage you to take a
look at Todd's very fine essay on Stack
Exchange about pre-emptive evaluation in
general and preamp protect in particular
I don't see Todd in this room but he's
at the conference very useful
information on this page well beyond the
scope of this talk but I think would be
useful to people who want to to take
their knowledge up a step so that's
preempt protection there's also some
abort protection that one can leverage
and remember a few slides back I told
you that there was a button that didn't
quite work as well as it could have well
that's because you know users are
finicky and they can change their mind
they kick off some long-running
evaluation and maybe they'll sit there
and let it complete or maybe they'll try
to interrupt it or abort it here we have
an interface the user has successfully
aborted this evaluation is not doing
anything anymore other than continuing
to show you evidence that maybe it's
doing something but it's not doing
anything the evaluation is done the cute
evaluation the cell bracket is not lit
up anymore there's nothing happening
here other than a spinner spinning on
screen how can this be refactored well
the colonel has a couple of constructs
for absorbing aborts in certain ways
there's abort protect and check about
there's there's ways to you know
determine if an abort has happened in a
certain body of code and if so to run
some cleanup and there's a way to say if
an aboard happens in this body of code
ignore it until this body of code is
complete so by adding those kinds of
awareness to this button function we can
say you know we can detect aborts in our
main thread of evaluation and if Anna
board is detected
and go do some cleanup right so here we
have you know if things evaluate all the
way through there's nothing there's
nothing to see if you abort then this
goes into a cleaning state and then
tells the user yeah okay un right so I
mean quite a little body of code but if
you have users that like aborting things
this is this is the kind of thing that
you'll need to do and I promised myself
this would be a bonus slide uh but I
will at least give you a flavor for it
so imagine you have a monitor and you
know what percentage of it it's done you
know you know how long how far along it
is in your do loop but you also know
that the evaluation it's progressing
through is very regular in it in the
speed with which it needs to handle
every step in that case the monitor
could in principle give you an estimate
for when the evaluation would be
complete and oh should I show this
example or not okay I'll show it I won't
show the implementation oh I won't show
the implementation but you know if you
have a very regular evaluation you know
this is not going to sort of
automatically give you a countdown timer
for integrate you know if you can happen
to know that your things are very very
regularly you know there's a cadence to
the evaluation that doesn't change much
over time then you might add this kind
of this kind of monitor and the code is
left in this closed bonus section I
encourage you to get the notebook and
that's really all I wanted to talk about
so and we have the ideal 10 minutes for
questions yes
playing with it is a great way they're
there if you if you I mean it requires a
little bit of knowledge about the box
structure I don't know if you went to
Jason's talk immediately before this one
but you would need to know things like
like the frame option for density plot
maps to the frame option for graphics
box whereas the plot points option maps
to a different branch of the plot
Colonel evaluation you can get lists of
box options I mean so so you can look in
the option inspector to get a list of
graphics box options for instance to get
an awareness of which options are likely
to be likely to be to be to be
immediately passed through like this
yeah it's going to be a long 10 minutes
so I'm just standing here quietly
staring at you yes yes yes so the
question is let me see if I can find the
example question is when we looked at
the details of this dynamic module which
was created automatically by save
definitions it says two definitions for
X right takes a keen eye to definitions
for extras one there there's one there
why well really this is an artifact of
having used save definitions to build
this initialization section
so the question is why how is the first
argument to dynamic module different
from the initialization option to
dynamic module that's question okay so
dynamic module attempted syntactically
to mirror the syntax of module and when
you define things in a module you don't
put down values in the first argument to
a module you put own values there but
you don't put you know f of X colon
equals blah you put F right and in your
module declaration and then you define f
in the body of your module so and that's
the that's the paradigm that we followed
for dynamic module so the first argument
is where own values are stored and then
everything else is actually stored and
in a part of the expression that you
don't see until you look at so so so own
values are stored in the first argument
everything else is stored somewhere else
in the dynamic module does that put what
into the first argument but
syntactically that that's an that's not
that's a no-go so you're saying I could
do this you're saying we could have had
support of that and module could have
supported that too but module didn't and
we weren't going to break the mold so
you're suggesting this and this is this
is invalid in the module world and it's
invalid in the dynamic module world yes
but I mean maybe in a in an alternate
universe we could have supported
something like this yep
yes
okay the question is I don't really
remember this thing but isn't it cool
maybe that's over so there's a there's a
cell there's a notebook dynamic
expression cell dynamic expression
there's even a front-end dynamic
expression and these are let's see we
saw a version of that in this talk we
saw the outlier the one that was named
as an outlier let me see if I can find
it it was the asynchronous checkbox so
dynamic wrapper is sort of the box
version of what you described it's the
ability to attach an arbitrary
expression that updates dynamically for
whenever the box is on screen but you
could have the same thing attached to
whenever a cell is on screen or whenever
a notebook is on screen or whenever the
front end is present and yes those are
front end dynamic expression notebook
dynamic expression cell so what what
have you used those for you said they
were useful
there are a couple of other hooks again
getting back to the non dynamic cases
notebook dynamic expression i think is
useful but there's also notebook there's
there's cell prologue and cell epilogue
which are things that are evaluated
before and after your your your cells
are evaluated and it and setting those
that the notebook scope can often be a
useful thing there's also event handlers
that you can set for a whole notebook to
change the be change what shift enter
does on a notebook or change what you
know typing the letter X does in a
notebook or in a cell or throughout the
front end where the numbers that around
20 10 good guess yep
it's similar but it's not the same and
in fact yes so watch the cell bracket
synchronous updating is true watch the
cell bracket as I release so both
updates are happening on the pre-emptive
link so if you are fast rendering is
fast enough to happen on the pre-emptive
link that's fine now yes are you asking
me to do that okay so let's change that
one to a seven and I don't even have to
actually let's see what did I do wrong
here ah it's busting so there you go and
so if I started to drive us around it's
not even going to switch over because
Jason broke my example okay right but
synchronous updating true so both are
happening on the on the pre-emptive on
the preemptive side singers updating
false both are happening on the oath
I've really busted things okay where is
it what am i doing there we go so now
notice that even when I'm dragging the
slider around the cell brackets blinking
away because even these are happening as
cute evaluations five six seven okay
okay
you